hey guys so this is something of an
update video loads of stuffs been going
on and there's quite a lot of stuff
coming in the future so I felt like I
should do it just a quick video to sort
of explain what's coming out on this
channel in the future and what's
happening with me so for a variety of
reasons which I won't go into right now
but I will in the future my funding for
my PhD Oxford disappeared but
fortunately I was lucky enough to get
funding and a place to study for a PhD
here where I am now at the University of
Exeter my PhD is in pretty much exactly
the same thing that I would have been
doing in Oxford which is the dynamical
coupling of the troposphere and
stratosphere and that's something which
I'm going to be making videos about in
the future but I need to learn more
about it before I can do something
really comprehensive in essence it's to
do with how the troposphere which is the
lowest part of the atmosphere the bit
which we breathe the bit which has our
weather and interacts with the next
layer up of the atmosphere which is the
stratosphere people used to think that
they weren't very connected to one
another but there's a lot of behavior in
the stratosphere which affects what
happens in the troposphere and
vice-versa
concurrent to that change in plan then
the biggest change which has happened to
me has been that I am now in Exeter
which is a really really nice place I
visited once before quite a long time
ago so it was kind of like we jumping in
the deep end without any idea what to
expect when I moved here but the Uni is
very different from Oxford the most
important difference is the fact that
the University of Exeter is not
collegiate like Oxford is so everyone is
in one big melting pot and they're not
separated by colleges like some Peters
or Christchurch or Matt or whatever what
this means is that the central
facilities which the university has here
are significantly better most the time
than oxygens facilities because things
like for example sport tend to be
divided up on a college basis in Oxford
whereas here we have a fantastic six and
a half million pound gym which was just
completed I'm very lucky to be here now
actually because loads of building works
just finished my accommodation block is
pretty much brand new the central
library is brand new the sports
facilities around you and the forum
which is like the universities I guess
like focal point it's got a
great hole that you're graduating it's
got the library and it's got a
supermarket and the Student Union and
all that kind of stuff in that's
brand-new the other difference is that
what Oxford kind of looks something like
this Exeter is more like this and in
order to get anywhere in what in order
to get to the campus in the morning I
have to get this thing called cardiac
Hill which is so cool because you have a
heart attack point of ego of it but it
is a lovely city and the people here are
really really nice I'm really really
happy
I've got involved in quite a few student
societies already the History Society
even though I do physics and I'm very
scientifically minded I've always found
the humanities in history in particular
to be very interesting so the history
Society did a trip to the set of
medieval tunnels which exist underneath
Exeter how tall are you Simon I've also
joined the campus cinema Society so one
of the many facilities which the central
campus has here is a student-run cinema
and I love it so much they're showing
two films a week and if you remember
it's two pounds for a ticket and it's
completely run by students they don't
have a digital projection system which i
think is my favorite thing about the
whole thing
it's not a digital projector it's those
old fashioned celluloid reels that like
four foot across and then there's a
xenon lamp behind them which projectiles
at the screen which I don't really quite
like but just having a cinema ten
minutes walk away which cost to quit is
not bad the thing which I got most
involved in however here is the acapella
Society so I mentioned in my life and
letters tag video that um I sang
previously and I sang in a barbershop
group here I successfully amazingly
auditioned for two of the a cappella
groups in the university the madrigals
who are a group that do medieval music
so well not quite medieval music it's it
tends to be more like 1673 seventeenth
century maybe kind of music which is
really fun another group is called
harmonics they're kind of like the
general classical group
there are like seven or so different
groups in the university just just a
cappella groups but which do different
materials and that's just the stuff
which I find most interesting to sing
with classical stuff and a medieval
stuff so probably it's going to be some
footage on YouTube at some point me
singing and I'm going to be horrendously
embarrassed speaking of the magicals of
the wonderful MD Jenny of the group is
going to be taking part in Movember
now some of you may remember that I took
part in Movember last year which I
looked seriously creepy but because
she's a girl she has to kind of eight
things along so Jenny for the entire
month of November is going to be wearing
a fake mustache there is a donation page
which I have put on the screen and in
the description if you would like to
support this frankly bonkers idea then
you're very very welcome to the reason I
am here though of course is to work and
to work on climate physics anyone who
follows me on Twitter which is at Simon
Hawks visit you'd like to all know that
I've been recently wrestling with trying
to program a climate model of my own
teaching myself Python which is a
programming language that the Met Office
now used for its climate models so I was
trying to make a very crew climate model
using that language as a method of
teaching it to myself and I'm probably
going to end up posting quite a few
videos on the stuff which I'm
researching specifically I have been
looking at a theory called potential
vorticity theory which I will need to
make a video about Wow actually really
worked in short it's a theory which
allows you to trace where parcels of air
in the atmosphere have come from so
specifically whether they've come from
the lower atmosphere or the upper
atmosphere and work out their kinematics
so how they evolve over time depend on a
quantity which we call the potential
vorticity which is related to how a
fluid spins but I'm going to need to
make a video the other video which is
going to be coming out very soon is of
my graduation so I am now officially an
Oxford graduate and I graduated with a
load of other people from my college in
shadowing in theater I'm not going to
talk about anymore
that is a whole video in itself and it's
there's some important stuff and want to
say but as proof
lastly the oxblood project which is a
continuation of my vlogs from last year
is now up and running we have had 5
vlogs already on the channel and a large
number of subscribers are join things
are really really kicking off so go and
check out youtube.com forward slash ox
log for the actual videos and if you
would like to like on Facebook we're at
facebook.com forward slash ox blog where
we will post every video that is
uploaded so you don't miss anything and
we're probably going to be doing some
more interesting stuff on the Facebook
as well I'm really really excited to see
where this project goes it's I think
it's going to be really really useful to
applicants and it's gonna I think it
might change the way the universities
think about access which is really
exciting but I think that's quite enough
frivolity for long video sorry this is
probably gonna end up being really non
boring and not at all what you signed up
to this channel for sorry about that
but I'll be coming up with some more
videos soon about my graduation about
the work which I'm doing and probably
just a few sciency maxy type videos
which I just think would be cool so
please stick around for those oh Jesus
over microphones on yeah